هل الشعر الشعبي والاطلاع عليه ضروري لفهم
التاريخ المحلي لا شك الجزيره العربيه
كان يغيب عنها التدوين في فترات زمنيه
سابقه
او انها تقريبا تمتد الى الف سنه تقريبا
اهملت في هذا الجانب لكن الشعر جاري على
اللسان اهل الجزيره العربيه والشعر كان هو
الوسيله الاعلاميه والوثيقه التاريخيه
الداله على حياه المجتمع في تلك الفتره
حيث ان القصائد تحتوي على دلالات
وتحمل رؤى معينه وتعكس حياه اجتماعيه او
سياسيه جرت على هذه الجزيره العربيه ولذلك
هي مهمه وكنز اغفل في فترات زمنيه سابقه
بنظر له على ان الشعر عام
هذه همم يعني تعتقد انه انه الباحثين يمكن
بعض الاكاديميين ممكن حتى الباحثين غير
السعوديين ما اهتموا بهذا الامر يمكن
الباحثين غير السعوديين اهتم نفهم يعني
لانهم لا يستطيعون تذوق او فهم مغازي هذه
الابيات وخلفياتها واجوائها لكن بعض
الباحثين السعوديين خلينا نقول ما هو موقف
الرواد يعني الشيخ محمد الجاسم بن خميس
الرواد الاوائل بليه هند ابن العبودي الله
يرحمهم جميعا وحتى الشعر الجنوب هل كانوا
على موقف واحد من الافاده من الشعر الشعبي
تتفاوت المواقفهم وتقريبا لم يتم همم
الغوص في النصوص الشعريه باستخراج
دلالاتها الكامله او تحقيقها وانما كان
همم
تعاملهم تقريبا تعامل سطحي مع اراد النص
كما هو همم لكن لما تبحث في النصوص وتنظر
الى العمق في نصوص همم عندنا طلعناها لها
600 سنه 700 سنه 400 سنه فهذه لها دلالات
معينه وكان ان الناس ترى انه اقصى حد
للنصوص الشعريه العاميه 200 سنه ولكن
بالبحث والتحقيق
ومقارنه بين المخطوطات طلعنا بخصوص